(gentle music)
Okay, Dr. Conner, take it away.
Pulmonary III.
Thank you, David.
Let's jump in. Pulmonary infections.
So in 2019, the Infectious Disease Society of America,
American Thoracic Society, updated their guidelines
for the diagnosis and treatments
of community-acquired pneumonia,
so a few things have changed since then.
Interestingly, pneumonias are still the eighth
leading cause of death in the United States.
The mortality rate disproportionately affects
the extremes of ages, as you might expect.
How do bacteria get into the lungs and set up a problem?
Well, there's three areas.
You can inhale the bacteria.
Interestingly, we'll talk about this in a moment.
There's a specific bacteria
that likes to live in the air ducts,
that if you have been in a hotel or a cruise ship
and within the next two weeks develop pneumonia,
you should be tested for what?
Legionella, right.
Legionella lives up in the air ducts.
Named after a famous convention,
Legionnaires Convention in Philadelphia, I believe in 1976,
there's a minor version of the illness
called Pontiac Fever,
Pontiac from North of Detroit where I live.
And that tends to be more the fever
without the respiratory problem, but also due to Legionella.
Anyway, you can breathe the bacteria in,
you can aspirate it,
or it can spread via the hematogenous route.
For example, if you had pyelonephritis, for example,
and it moved up to the lungs via the bloodstream.
The etiology here, this one's easy,
common pathogen Strep pneumo, Myco, Chlamydia, H. flu.
What's more interesting are the less common pathogens
and even more interesting than that
are the modifying factors.
So this is what I want you to pay attention to.
We all know Strep pneumo,
but what changes our thinking
from the ordinary to the atypical?
And here's what they are.
So young patients age four months to four years,
RSV is you're more likely agent it.
Age 5 to 18, it's Mycoplasma pneumoniae.
Now, these are also very important modifying factors.
Look at these.
If a patient's alcoholic,
you wanna think anaerobes and Klebsiella.
Aspiration, anaerobes.
Bioterrorism, those are the agents that you might consider.
Thankfully, we haven't seen bioterrorism in a minute,
but could still happen.
COPD patients tend to be infected with H. flu or M. cat.
Exposure to farm animals or droppings,
Histo, Blasto, and Cocci are your fungal organisms.
And we will discuss those later this afternoon
'cause those wills show up on the boards, I guarantee.
Hotel or cruise ship travel, within the past two weeks,
as we just mentioned, Legionella.
Post influenza, think Staph aureus.
These are very important to remember for the boards,
as well as clinical practice, as are these.
Increased risk for drug-resistant Strep pneumo,
age greater than 65.
Any broad spectrum antibiotics within the last three months.
The boards like to ask the question,
well, he was at the dentist, you know, a month or two ago
and was put on clindamycin or whatnot,
amoxicillin for his dental infection,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Now what should you do to treat his pneumonia?
Well, he's up to a high risk group now
because the dentist gave him a broad spectrum antibiotic
in the last three months.
Alcohol abuse, immunosuppressive illnesses,
multiple medical comorbidities,
obviously including diabetes.
Exposure to children in a daycare center
increases your risk for drug resistant strep.
Very interesting.
And like I said,
they love to throw these questions at you on the boards.
Increased risk for MRSA. I've had MRSA in the past.
A lot of patients tend to be carriers as you know.
Hospitalization and antibiotics in the last 90 days,
or locally validated factors that might include MRSA
and immunocompromised patients.
Keep all of those in mind.
Your presentation of pneumonia, typical presentation,
you all know how to diagnose pneumonia, that's easy.
What's more interesting is the atypical presentations,
which can be subacute.
In elderly, they can come across
as maybe functional decline.
The physical exam symptoms might be more subtle.
They might only include one respiratory symptom,
but they may have a bunch of other
extra pulmonary symptoms as well.
So keep that in mind with your atypical pneumonias.
Also, social travel, like I'll give you a test question
this afternoon about a patient
who was visiting a certain part of the country
and came back with an atypical pneumonia.
Okay, let's get started with a question.
Now, here's our case.
A 55-year-old male presents, wait a minute,
didn't I say that I don't use sex
in the stem of my question except unless what?
Right, so a 55-year-old male
presents with a four-day history of productive cough, fever,
some dull right flank pain, and mild dyspnea.
Past medical history is significant
for diabetes and hypertension.
His exam is unremarkable
besides a temperature of 101 degrees Fahrenheit,
respirations of 22,
pulse of 110,
BP 100/70.
There is dullness to percussion
and some crackles in the left base.
A chest x-ray shows a left lower lobe infiltrate.
We all know what's going on here.
Treatment is initiated.
Which one of the following is true
concerning further diagnostic studies in this case?
A, a chest CT is recommended.
B, a chest x-ray should be repeated in one to two weeks.
C, no further diagnostic studies are recommended
if symptoms resolve.
Or D, ultrasound of chest and abdomen is recommended.
Dr. Holt mentioned this to you earlier
how the boards love to do this to you.
They really ask you two questions in one.
This one's pretty straightforward,
but quite often, they'll present a case like this
and you have to know what the diagnosis is.
But the question may be, you know, what is the treatment
or what's the next step?
So they're really tricking you
into answering two questions at once.
The boards love to do that.
In this case, we have a patient with pneumonia, right?
Community-acquired pneumonia.
So what should we do for follow up, if anything?
Good, no further diagnostic studies recommended
if the symptoms resolve.
That's a change from the previous
community-acquired pneumonia guidelines
where they recommended a follow up chest x-ray.
Really, you know, you don't need a chest x-ray
to diagnose pneumonia.
I can diagnose pneumonia with a history and my stethoscope,
but you're gonna get the chest x-ray anyway
because it may exclude some other causes,
confirms your diagnosis,
so it's just standard of care to do a chest x-ray
when you suspect pneumonia.
Your classic, you know, Strep pneumo
is like this right middle lobe, you know,
consolidated lobar lesion.
Your atypicals may be more the fluffy interstitial
bat wing type of appearance.
Don't forget about false negatives with dehydrated
or elderly patients.
And again, repeat chest x-rays no longer recommended.
Here's a couple radiographs.
On the left, we see that typical
right middle lobe infiltrate.
Classic, classic pneumonia,
And then on the right, an atypical,
that kind of fluffy bat wing type of appearance
that you may see.
You can also use ultrasound
to diagnose pneumonia if you have it available,
and an experienced sonographer
that can be used at the bedside
and can be helpful to detect other disorders as well.
And CT, especially if you're suspecting
interstitial lung diseases,
a tumor, sarcoid, or a malignancy.
This is new too.
Testing for specific pathogens with cultures
and urine testing antigens is unnecessary now
for most outpatients.
If they're in the unit, completely different story.
However, if they've been on antibiotics in the last 90 days
or they're severe,
you might wanna consider these other risk factors.
These next two slides are for you to take home and study.
This tells you every test
that should be ordered in each individual case.
Your normal patient you treated as an outpatient
doesn't need blood cultures or sputum cultures, okay?
But this tells you alcohol abuse, asplenia,
cavitary infiltrate, chronic liver disease,
outpatient treatment failure,
ICU admit, leukopenia, pleural effusion, severe COPD,
or recent travel, what tests you should order.
Okay, next question.
Same case.
When deciding whether to treat your 55-year-old
with pneumonia as an outpatient
or to admit them to the hospital,
in addition to clinical judgment,
which one of the following tools
or tests would be most helpful?
Would it be A, the CURB-65?
B, the Pneumonia Severity Index or PSI?
C, procalcitonin level?
Or D, SMART-COP?
One of these tools is most helpful if we're unsure
whether we should admit the patient to the hospital or not.
Sometimes with the boards, it's gonna be pretty obvious.
You know, they're gonna have
a hemodynamically unstable patient
or there's something else going on
where it's obvious they need to be in the hospital.
In other cases, it may be more subtle
and that's where questions like this can come in.
Okay, so we have just a slight majority here.
So learning opportunity, the PSI is the correct answer.
It used to be the CURB-65.
So those of you who answered that,
you're still thinking it with the older guidelines.
The PSI is the newer one.
How about biomarkers?
How many like procalcitonin levels
in their pneumonia patient?
I know they do them a lot in the hospital.
They're considered out now.
They're just not, they're not sensitive and specific enough.
So your own clinical judgment
now overrules the procalcitonin level.
The difference here might be if you had a patient
who had superimposed CHF
and you weren't sure whether to initiate antibiotics,
then you might order one in that case.
So back to the risk stratification scores,
the Pneumonia Severity Index is a prognostic model.
So it is now recommended over the CURB-65
severity of index score.
So here's what it looks like.
So over on the left, you stratify based on age.
First off, over 55 years of age, our patient was 55,
so he gets a yes for that.
And then you move on to step number two, he's male.
So you add his age in years, so 55.
If female, you subtract 10.
So men are at higher risk than women.
That's why the sex of the patient
was included in the stem of the question
is because of this PSI.
And then you move along.
He doesn't have any of the rest of these risks,
so he is stratified to Risk Class II.
So that's the PSI and how it works.
Class I or II, you could probably
send them home on oral antibiotics.
Class III, you may or you may not admit them to the hospital
depending on other factors,
and IV or V should all be hospitalized for treatment.
Next question.
So same case, you decide to treat
your 55-year-old with pneumonia
and history of diabetes and hypertension as an outpatient.
The appropriate choice
for outpatient treatment in this case
is which one of the following?
Is it A, amoxicillin?
B, azithromycin?
C, cefuroxime?
Or D, levofloxacin?
The key here is there's something about this patient
that may be different from usual
and that's what you have to identify.
So again, it's asking you
those two questions at once, right?
Is this just a normal patient with no other risk factors
and we need to stick with the first line agent,
or is there an additional risk factor at play here
that might kick us up into a further category?
Good, the majority of you got the correct answer,
which is levofloxacin.
The reason is because he's diabetic.
So let's get into these.
So there are four treatment categories
for community-acquired pneumonia.
I should also say that healthcare-associated pneumonia,
HCAP, that's gone now.
How many remember that one, healthcare associated?
No, no, no, it's out.
It's all community-acquired pneumonia now
with these new guidelines.
So we have four treatment categories,
this is pretty straightforward here.
Category one is outpatient with he's healthy,
no risks for drug resistant Strep or MRSA.
No antibiotics in the last three months.
Nothing else is going on.
Number two, outpatient, but with comorbidities.
In this case, our patient had what? Diabetes.
So because he's diabetic,
he's now in treatment category number two.
Or if they've been on recent antibiotics
in the past three months,
including at the dentist or the urgent care.
Keep that in mind that.
That question in particular loves to show up on the boards
about the recent antibiotics.
A third treatment category is inpatient but not severe,
so you need expanded coverage.
And then your last treatment category is severe pneumonia
as an inpatient or in the ICU
and you're gonna throw everything,
with the kitchen sink at those, right?
So it's pretty straightforward.
Let's take a look at them.
So it has changed a bit.
So treatment category one, outpatient, previously healthy,
no risk for drug-resistant Strep.
Amoxicillin is what we're back to.
You can also use doxy if they're penicillin allergic.
Macrolides again have fallen out of favor
largely because of the resistance to Strep pneumo.
So if your local resistance to Strep pneumo is low,
you could still consider Zithromax.
But for the purpose of the boards,
I would stick with amoxicillin.
Number two, outpatient with comorbidities
or recent antibiotics.
This was our 55-year-old with diabetes.
You need to either do a beta-lactam plus a macrolide,
so that would be Augmentin and Zithromax,
or a respiratory quinolone.
That's why the answer to that question was levofloxacin.
The FDA statement on quinolones in 2016
scared everybody to bits.
"Oh my god, don't prescribe quinolones at all
ever, ever, ever."
Not quite.
With serious bacterial infections,
the benefits of quinolones outweigh the risk.
So they get these prescriptions from the pharmacy
and they have a list of warnings this long,
and I future pace my patients.
You're gonna get a scary list from CVS
and you try not to pay too much attention
because in your case, the benefit outweighs that risk.
Okay, moving on to group number three, non-severe inpatient.
You're gonna do the respiratory quinolone
or the beta-lactam plus the macrolide,
but in this case, it's probably gonna be intravenous.
And then your severe patients,
you're gonna do all of this plus more
depending on, you know, what else you find
with your antigen testing and cultures and so forth.
So fairly straightforward.
Now, this chart shows the differences
between the 2007 guideline and the new 2019 guideline.
So procalcitonin is out,
corticosteroids are out unless they're septic.
We no longer obtain a followup chest x-ray
and the use of healthcare-associated pneumonia
as a category is out.
So those are the biggest changes.
Okay, now let's move to another infection.
So we've covered community-acquired pneumonia,
I think pretty straightforward.
Adult pertussis or whooping cough is next.
This is, of course, due to Bordetella pertussis.
I would memorize that bacteria name.
They sometimes like to ask these questions as well.
So do know that pertussis is due to Bordetella pertussis.
It's in the name, pretty easy.
So these patients just have
cough, cough, cough, cough, cough that won't stop.
They have paroxysms of cough
that can actually fracture a rib or cause them to pass out.
Way back in the day, we actually had a whoop
where they would cough, cough, cough, cough, cough.
(sucking in breath deeply)
You know, they would suck in the air.
That's the whoop from whooping cough.
You don't really see that anymore,
but you do see these persistent
cough, cough, cough, cough, cough patients as adults.
There's three stages to pertussis.
Stage 1 is the catarrhal stage.
You know, they're having upper respiratory type symptoms.
A lot of mucus that's clear.
If you can recognize it and treat it,
you can shorten the disease course at this stage.
So this is really interesting.
In fact, they recommend that you do it.
The problem is how?
You know, a patient comes in with upper respiratory.
I'm not always thinking pertussis.
So it really is tricky.
I guess you would, if on the boards,
they would probably give you some extra information
like recently exposed to pertussis
and now presents with, you know,
a respiratory symptom and cough,
in which case you would treat.
Stage 2 is the paroxysmal stage.
This can go on for weeks
where they have these uncontrolled paroxysms of cough.
Treatment at this stage isn't gonna lessen their disease,
but it might help prevent the spread.
And then Stage 3 is the convalescent phase,
which lasts a few weeks
and they're still infectious at that time.
You can diagnose this with nasal PCR testing more likely
than to do a culture.
And the treatment here is azithromycin
'cause remember Zithromax and usually doxy
will cover some of these atypical agents like this.
So in this case, azithromycin is the drug of choice.
Post-exposure prophylaxis would be recommended
in household contacts.
They did ask me that question last spring on the boards
about a mother whose child had pertussis
and what to do with her.
And then the prevention is the TDAP vaccine.
Viral lung infections, influenza is the most common.
Of course, it's a winter spread.
Very abrupt onset of symptoms.
Patients with influenza will be like, "I was fine.
And then boom, like it hit me like a Mack Truck,
and now I've got the body aches, the cough, the fever.
I went from, you know, it went from 0 to 100 like that."
That's how fast influenza hits.
Aerosolized spread like many viruses.
The current recommendation by the CDC
is not to wait on testing.
If you have high clinical suspicion,
you should go ahead and treat,
especially if they are in a high risk group as listed.
Tamiflu is still the preferred drug.
You also have inhaled Relenza,
unless you have a patient with asthma or COPD.
Peramivir inpatient, and Xoflusa.
Now, and don't forget, you can do chemoprophylaxis
if a high-risk patient has been exposed
or certainly you should in an institutional setting.
What's interesting to me is that Tamiflu and Xoflusa
work by different mechanisms,
but I'm not aware of a clinical study
that shows doing both at the same time.
But I would be interested in that study.
But for the purposes of the boards,
Tamiflu is still the preferred drug.
Okay, RSV, so much press and headlines
RSV has gotten this year,
very common also in the winter
along with COVID and with influenza,
so we have three circulating viruses now,
not to mention adenovirus
and all the other causes of the common cold.
So most patients just have an upper respiratory type symptom
for five days.
Sicker patients are gonna get more pneumonia symptoms.
And, of course, don't forget that your CHF patients,
your asthmatics and COPDs are certainly gonna go into
an exacerbation when they have an RSV infection.
It's recommended that we should consider this in any adult
with URI symptoms during the fall and winter
and test them with PCR.
The reason that it's nice to test
'cause we have, you know, PCR testing now, I can do a swab
and test for RSV, COVID, and influenza all at the same time.
So the treatment changes,
you know, depending on the result of that test.
If it's RSV, that treatment is supportive
provided they get over it within a week.
You know, patients who you are sick longer than a week
with their upper respiratory infection,
we start thinking what?
Rhinosinusitis, Dr. Holt talked about this earlier today.
So that's that double whammy situation,
you know, I had this upper respiratory infection,
lasted about a week, I thought I was getting better,
and then now it's back again with the,
you know, the mucus production,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
That's the time that you would diagnose
acute bacterial rhinosinusitis.
Okay, now moving on to the difficult part,
pneumococcal vaccinations, okay?
David touched on this,
but we're going to dive into it a little bit deeper.
So we traditionally had two vaccines, right?
We had the conjugate 13-valent vaccine
that works via a T cell response.
And then we had the polysaccharide 23-valent vaccine,
which works via a B cell response, right?
That's what we had, but it's changed.
So next question. Same case.
Our 55-year-old patient with diabetes and hypertension
comes in for a routine health maintenance visit.
They have no history of receiving a pneumococcal vaccine.
When discussing vaccination for prevention of pneumonia,
which one of the following options
would be preferred in this case?
A, PCV15 now and PPSV23 at age 65.
So wait till he's 65 for one,
give him the other now.
B, PCV20 now.
C, PPPSV23 at age 65 only.
Or D, PPSV23 now and again at age 65.
One of these is the preferred recommendation
based on the newest guidelines.
Okay, great, y'all are wonderful.
So the correct answer is B, PCV20 now. Good.
So we now have other options.
In addition to the 13-valent conjugate, we have a 15-valent
and a 20-valent conjugate vaccine
in addition to the 23-valent polysaccharide vaccine.
So we know that the PCV20 by itself
or if you do the PCV15 in series a year later
with the polysaccharide,
very effective at reducing pneumococcal disease.
So the recommendations are these, this came out in 2022.
All adults 65 or older who've not previously been vaccinated
should get one dose of the the PCV20.
One dose of the PCV20. And that's it.
Now, if you don't have the Prevnar 20,
you could do the 15 and then wait a year
and follow it with the Pneumovax, okay?
That's the new recommendation.
Medicare does pay for the PCV20.
It's an expensive vaccine, but very effective.
T cell immunity is much more potent than B cell immunity.
A great example of a cutaneous cell immune problem is what?
Poison ivy. Y'all know how terrible that could be.
That's an immune response via T cells.
Now what if I'm between 19 and 64? Can I get the vaccine?
Yes, if you have certain underlying conditions,
and there's a lot of them, look at it.
Alcoholism, chronic liver disease, heart-lung disease,
stage 3 renal failure.
I smoke cigarettes or I'm diabetic.
Jesus, this is almost everyone.
So they're making it easier and easier and easier for us
to give these vaccines.
So if in our case our patient was 55,
but he had diabetes, so he needs the PCV20 now.
Okay.
Generally, you're gonna wait a year
if you're doing the PCV15 and pneumococcal option.
It gets tricky here.
What I would like to say is this,
this is the bottom line here.
You've got two vaccine options
and you only need one of them once as an adult
and never again.
That's much easier than it used to be.
I think for the boards, you're gonna see the PCV20 option.
That's it. That's all they need.
They never need another vaccine again.
You could do the PCV15, wait a year and do the PSV23.
But I think for boards,
you're gonna see do the PCV20 once and done.
If you're unsure of what to do in this watershed area,
well, you know, he had one vaccine a couple years ago,
I don't know, blah, blah, blah.
They give you a website to go to,
the PneumoRecs VAxAdvisor to help you out.
Okay, that is the pneumococcal vaccine.
I think it's pretty straightforward.
If you really think about it,
it's a one and done, you know, vaccine now
if you do the PCV20 option.
Try to keep that in your mind
and not make it more complicated than it needs to be.
Other recommended vaccines, of course, COVID,
influenza, and TDAP.
Now, there's a lot of other
hidden slides in here about COVID.
I will tell you, when I took the boards in April last year,
I did not have one single test question about COVID-19.
Didn't see one.
I can't say that that's gonna be the case
when you all take the exam,
but I didn't have one test question about COVID.
RSV, of course, is a new vaccine that's out for adults
age 60 and older at higher risk,
but they also give you the frail advanced age
or anyone that you worry option, which is kind of everybody.
So they give you that
to kinda get everyone immunized against RSV, which is nice.
So you do this vaccine in the fall or winter,
it's a single dose, pretty straightforward.
And then lastly, respiratory infection,
avoid close contact, stay home when you're sick.
You know, we live in this crazy culture in the US
where, you know, "Oh, I'm terribly sick.
What do you mean you're not coming to work?"
It should be the opposite.
"You're sick?
Why are you here? Go home."
You know, because we're spreading these things around.
The work culture in the United States is great,
but it's also sometimes our Achilles' heel.
Masks can help protect others.
And, of course, you know, good health habits.
(audience applauding)